so back at it again there's a third time
right being Lego Batman yeah you're tied
now for like the ground rail right yeah
of being like the most Batman yeah he
and I obviously we get mentioned in a
lot of the same sentences Christian Bale
and I do yeah we're up for a lot of the
same parts so it makes sense to me it's
like when they did that animated Dick
Cheney movie and you did stunning
performance yeah
yeah no it's really fun to be able to
play this character for the third time
in a movie and and I think it might I
get to play the fun Batman mm-hmm you
know I get to just show up and goof
around yeah I love Batman's new wardrobe
change in this movie dude would you like
to see that look sort of translate into
live-action for whatever they went over
that next Batman movie that they end up
but they keep talking about yeah that
would be pretty fun wouldn't it to see
him in like the disco Batman in
live-action yeah I think that's what
they're missing
those ones well cause one of the great
things about doing the Lego Batman is we
get to see the other side of that man
and so it would be kind of nice to see
that in a live-action version yeah maybe
maybe I could do that I think that would
be yeah I don't know if you have any
heat you know the people over there but
everybody say let them know um so this
movie with a big theme in this is kind
of like a sibling rivalry I guess like
you know brother and sister arguing your
boys at home do they argue a lot how do
you keep the peace at home between
between the kids actually to be honest I
what I usually do is if the kids yeah of
course they'd you know they're 8 and 10
to boys so they all disagree over things
were fight over the same toys or
whatever it is and I always just slide
into not necessarily I don't think of it
as Batman but I just think I I never
yellow or raise my voice I just go down
to here Oh like everybody stop what
you're doing right now and that kind of
they can feel that and like through
their bones right scares them and I find
that scaring kids is really effective
they immediately think of the Dark
Knight yeah when you go into that mo and
they're just like I don't want any of it
yeah yeah but actually the only thing
that really works with
kids these days with my kids is just
threatening to take away the iPad I
threatened to like like throw it out in
you know out of the car or somehow done
and they're like anything but that I'll
sue actually yeah oh you know when your
kids are playing superheroes like if
they're if they're playing Batman do
they do your voice as Batman like which
Batman do they do they don't really do
my voice I mean they have done it before
but you know last summer we did this I
produced this film this a film version
of Teen Titans go - yeah let's go to the
movies and there's a Batman in there so
I asked Jimmy Kimmel came in and did the
voice of Batman it's just a couple lines
and he kept telling my sons that he was
the current reigning Batman and to get
over it he's really funny and so my son
my youngest son said to him like well
let's hear let's hear your Batman and so
Jimmy was like and he kind of went like
am Batman or whatever and my son went
yeah I was pretty good and then he turns
to me he goes hit it boy like I worked
for him and did you jump that or really
I had to okay you know so anyway it was
it was fun to be able to shame Kimmel in
that way that's nice
yeah that's nice to be able to do that
to your friends your kids well you have
to show your superiority are you
competitive guy probably more
competitive than you are right I'm out I
would concede and say absolutely I'm
just as much as the next person probably
but no more when you when you were with
James Corden and you guys were all
competing at NASA yes to be the next you
know the next astronaut would actually
were you how serious were you about that
cuz it's everyone's dream in a way yeah
so really to be an asteroid like
everyone wants to get in the city every
muscle builder man right I wanted to
Elizabeth Banks won the the challenge
was to see which one of us could be most
likely to be an astronaut who has the
right stuff yeah and this this guy was
an astronaut's guy who'd gives him
really nice dude
he gave it he said that Elizabeth won
which again I want to recount on that
but it was you know it was a lot of fun
that we did the gyro thing we're hanging
around that almost brought that
literally brought me to my knees I
I almost booted right there so is it
it's like I guess it goes without saying
that's harder than it looks but how much
harder was it well you know you do that
thing and they put you in that I forget
what they call and they you like I said
difficult yeah yeah get a couple cheese
on you you ended up having like three or
four G's oh geez that was yeah tons so
many cheese so many G's and it it felt
like somebody's got like a piano on your
chest and that's you know like a third
of what they get yeah when they're
taking off or or even not even that much
so you know for me you know I always say
to all the astronauts and and jet
fighter pilots Matt ups Matt ups yeah I
don't know if that's a current
expression oh but I'm bringing it back
it took me a second yeah Matt apps
matches yeah